we've got beautiful skies on this
wednesday morning gorgeous as we look
out
across the southwest valley see a little
bit of downtown summerlin there and
out across the southwest part of the
spring mountains temperatures are pretty
warm we are still
in the upper 80s couple of neighborhoods
still right stuck in those low 90s
77 out at red rock some nice upper 60s
at kyle canyon
we've got a lot of heat that we're
facing in the west and they're facing a
lot of rain in florida right now
tropical storm elsa briefly reemerged as
a hurricane for a little while yesterday
but
it's downgraded but still a strong storm
putting out a lot of water
over florida strong winds a little bit
of storm surge
you can see all the heavy rain there it
is starting to bend
just a little bit to the northeast now
trying to make an
onshore approach there tornado warnings
flash flood warnings
also with the hurricane watches posted
across northern florida right now
we've got some live pictures that we're
bringing you
this is horseshoe beach this is just
north of cedar key on the west coast
very near tropical storm elsa right now
and you can see the coast is
getting a little splash there with some
waves doesn't look too intense
the storm will turn away from the west
coast and start moving inland now
for the next few hours let's take a look
at the track of elsa
where the storm is going to go it will
head over northern florida
into southern georgia today and then
continue into the carolinas if it stays
on this course
it will actually stay a tropical storm
with heavy
rain and some pretty good winds and that
will continue
all the way through the end of the week
so the carolinas will get a good taste
of elsa as well back here in the west
another
long lasting heatwave for us we've got
heat warnings that will take effect in a
little more than an hour at eight
o'clock this morning
going all the way until eight o'clock
monday night monday night
this is a very long lasting
intense heat wave again for us highs in
the 1 teens
this is for the lower elevations the
higher elevations
above 4000 feet the mountains will be
under heat advisories for that same time
frame
we're looking at mount charleston kyle
canyon looking at temperatures in the
mid 90s
mid to low 90s in lee canyon probably in
those mid 80s for highs so it is going
to be warm up there
114 for us today 115 is
the record you've got to stay hydrated
please don't overdo it out in the heat
it's just that heat takes its toll so
quickly even before you realize it
will likely tie and even set new record
highs as we get through the week
1 15 on saturday looks to be the hottest
these numbers could change a little
might even go up to 116. we've been
there
before already this summer back in june
we'll get a break
later next week